so let's take a quick look at the code
to query for all the conference entities
so here i am in the conference api dot
java file or conference appi
file and the query conferences method so
you'll notice it's declared has it at
appy method annotation the name query
conferences path query conferences and
the http method is httpmethod.post
so to query for the conferences you
create the query of type conference
and then you call off fee.load.type
specifying the entity class which in
this case is conference class and then
we want to order by name
to actually execute the query we call
the list method on the query and we're
going to return the results of running
the query which is going to be all the
conferences
ordered by name
and that's all there is to it